[Music]
julianne huff
is fighting to make things work with her
estranged hubby brooks like
[Music]
a source tells et that the couple who
split in may is working on repairing
their relationship
explaining quote julianne and brooks
both want to try to make things work
friends closest to them see this time as
very positive
they are hoping for a full
reconciliation the source adds that they
realize they had taken each other for
granted in the past
but now after having heart-to-heart
conversations the pair is working on
being open and respectful of each other
and both seem to want to make it work
according to our source one of the main
challenges facing them right now
is starting a family brooks is ready and
julianne
isn't quite there yet i go through waves
i'm like so into it and then i'm like
i'm good
he's like you're like i'll just be ready
when you tell me
i'm just yeah basically i'm just along
for the ride in this one
yeah i don't think either of us will
really be ready
no i think it'll just have to happen
yeah news of julianne and brooks's
relationship repair comes on the heels
of the release of her music video for
transform
the emotional and heartfelt single she
released in september 2019
although the single was released a year
ago julianne explained in a lengthy
instagram caption
why she delayed dropping the video till
now quote
i was about to release this video when
the most tragic loss of my life abruptly
occurred
time passed and i felt i had missed my
window to release this video
the tragic loss the unexpected deaths of
her two dogs
lexi and harley jules continued in the
post that she wrote the song during a
highly transformative time in her life
and called this year her most
challenging yet
there's never a right time or anything
you just got to do what you got to do in
the moment and have it come from
like the most pure authentic and loving
place and
i am deciding that i am releasing this
today
because why not appreciate the peace